hallo mein name ist so herzlich
willkommen wir heute zum neuen video
seht ihr schon im titel eingeblendet und
zwar die besten profis
ich habe jetzt schon mal ein video
hochgeladen wo ich ebenfalls wegen die
bescheuerte lustige witzige facebook
videos euch gezeigt habe ja und jetzt
dass eigentlich alle relativ dollar
gefallen fing ganz ich mich so mehr
sieben videos raus und zeigt ihr euch
bei dem ersten video haben wir hier
einen ganz normalen volkswagen und man
denkt erst mal okay der steht da ist
vielleicht ein bisschen tiefer gelegt
aber dann macht er halt den motor an
autokenner denkt sich das schon so
dezidiert aber kein typischer sound für
die karre und ja das stimmt der ich
glaube dieser besitzer von dem auto
einem hat etwas an seiner motorisierung
beziehungsweise zumindest an seine
auspuffen gemacht aber ich meine sonne
etwas krasser motors zaun ist ja
eigentlich nicht schlimm
wir schauen uns das video mal weiter an
da kommen flammen aus dem auspuff aus
einem vw bei dem nächsten video gibt es
zwar etwas jüngere jungs ihre jungs der
junge hinter der kamera fragt auf jeden
fall erstmal den tüten dem anhalt
eingeblendet seht ihr university also
auf deutscher seite tätiger was
überhaupt machen was machen wir jetzt
gerade und der junge der vor der kamera
steht hat eine wodkaflasche in der hand
und antworte ja am herzen ich verstehe
nicht ganz genau aber irgendwie sowas in
der richtung ja ich habe jetzt eine
wodka und ich trinke jetzt bis zur
hälfte leer
mal schauen was er danach dann so sagt
lasst die hände vom alkohol kinder ins
nächste video ist ein ultra süßes
beziehungsweise auch witziges video da
geht es nämlich um einen hund und dieser
kleine hund soll laut seiner besitzerin
sagen welches plüschtier sein bester
freund ist der hund hat ihr zum beispiel
beim ersten mal auf diese milch gezeigt
und dann fragt die besitzerin halt noch
mal wieder in sein bester freund ist
nicht klein und der unterhalt wieder auf
den richtige zeigen fragt die besitzerin
noch mal wer der beste freunde ist nicht
immer und die besitze betrag die noch
mal und noch mal und noch mal antwortet
also immer wenn deine verschiedene
auswahl an flüchten vor sich hat dass es
immer der älteste dein bester freund ist
wo wir gerade nach unten sind habe ich
als nächstes video diesen jack russel
hier vorbereitet ich glaube es ist ein
jack russell ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung von hundemarken hundemarken wenig
eigentlich total bescheuert ihr sieht
jemand das video von dem wechsel einen
werden gerät schon es ist kein normaler
hund irgendwie mit dem knochen spielt
oder so sondern mit leoparden
beziehungsweise anderen raubtieren
lieber jack russel bist du lebensmüde
bei den nächsten video geht es um drei
kleinkinder und zwar ein kind im
vordergrund einzelne mittel 1
hintergrund was eigentlich gar nicht
mitspielen sondern einfach oder
rothschild jedenfalls hat das kind in
der mitte irgendwie eine tube zahnpasta
oder ich weiß dass ein schokoriegel ist
auf jeden fall irgendwas was die person
im vordergrund halt haben möchte
allerdings ist das kind was dieses
gewollte etwas besitzt davon nicht so
begeistert den anderen kindern etwas
davon abzugeben
ganz so stark dieser junge hält ihn da
so lebt jetzt in die kamera aufgeben
möchten das so hin begleiten sie dann
wieder weg wie früher
der junge mit dass man auf jeden fall
noch so 12 mal abgezogen und dann am
ende hat er dem jungen im vordergrund
dann doch etwas davon abgegeben und es
ist einfach ein ultra süßes video also
mit der jungen der mitte hat halt am
ende wieder so geguckt als wirklich
science gewesen wäre
beim nächsten video musik ich sage okay
das ist ein schöner sommertag die wollen
da will ein pärchen ausflug machen und
holt sich in stara will das zusammen
sich drauf schwingen und es sieht im
ersten moment auch wirklich alles nach
einem ganz normalen sonntags familien
video aus alles klappt super der parade
an schwung die frau sind schnitten drauf
doch dann will halt sein anderes bei mit
aufs rad nehmen
der award wird das dümmste vater am
steuer geht auf jeden fall an die
kollegen danke für den lacher bei dem
nächsten video sagt der protagonist
trainer armin veh als auch deutsche was
er jetzt seine hose anziehen wird
schauen wir einmal dabei zu und jetzt
kommt halt dieser moment wo er hat seine
rosen angezündet hat und dann denkt okay
jetzt mein t shirt stimmt dass darüber
und dann löscht das feuer wieder hat
halt nicht so ganz geklappt
wir schauen uns immer weiter angucken ob
es noch schafft
2000 jahre später
du bist auf jeden fall mein held des
tages
das war es jetzt hier familie meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
lassen auf jeden fall mal alleine da und
das auch leider nicht das ganze normal
machen soll schreibt mal in die
kommentare facebook
wenn ihr jetzt gar noch dran sein weil
dann sehe ich wäre die coolsten fans in
von der zuschauer bände und verlost an
reicht mein leben alles klar ihr findet
hier vornherein smiley eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren wird auf jeden fall unserer
ice von euch weiß eigentlich tatsächlich
nur scheiße hochladen und hier findet
ihr ein video eingebettet wo ich euch
die besten uk specialty hier irgendwie
aufgenommen wurden
ich habe richtig bock auf pizza gerade